the commercials
I'm a real actor this is an art form for
me I don't know you departed
I met David
after all this time in Hollywood people
would stop mixing up Ben Affleck and
Matt Damon you know it's wild to think
about it that way but such is life for
the Boston boys and Ben's poking funded
it all in a new ad how did you do when
you said you're going to work all day I
gotta go guys following that Super Bowl
spot Ben's back on screen for another
donut Run part of an endorsement deal
worth several million dollars here for
the Duncan run campaign commercial on
the menu that case of mistaken identity
I'm real actress is an art form for me
that's working overtime I met David I
know yeah I love him I love him I love
him I mean some of his work he kind of
got a really consistent career I think
it's a full circle moment for Ben he got
his first paycheck at a donut shop but
it was a far cry from Seven figures I
would got a job as a dishwasher in high
school it was basically like a donut
shop 130 bucks forget it I met David no
yeah I love him I love him this comes as
the pair of Oscar winners celebrate a
milestone reuniting 25 years after their
breakout movie I mean when you think
back yo it makes you old you know I
remember uh being too young to
understand or appreciate it you don't
know it to yourself
you owe it to me this is actually where
we premiered Goodwill Hunting like right
here
I'm nervous I'm really nervous now Ben
and Matt are reunited on the big screen
for the 1980s set air tell me about the
wig and the tights that was the gear
that was hot and 84
that was how you did it happen the whole
crew just was like
got a name for it
Air Jordan
I don't know
seriously maybe it'll grow on me that's
a good look it's back you don't know
that I don't know I don't my kids my son
rocks it looked all the time like that
along with the new movie and new ad kids
who grew up two blocks apart and both
wanted to be actors a Sentimental band
drops by the smartless podcast but it
really was a genuine thing where we were
like look I hope I get the part but if I
don't I really hope you do right and you
know for a while we had this thing where
we're like we'll just split all our
money we had a joint bank account very
few people are lucky enough to spend
their life in the same line of work with
their best friend when they were kids
the secret to working together is abuse
each other and so if you can't be honest
with the guy you work with who can you
be honest uh with I think because we you
know uh really don't pull any punches
when we uh critique they learn how to
take a hit you know I met David I know
yeah I love him I love him
I mean some of his were
[Music]
foreign